the sun is heating up out there and
drying out our skin so if you're
anything like me you are desperate for a
good hydra facial so katya from pearl
skin studios is back here with all the
hydration tips that we need i am ready
for sure
everyone so yes we're going to talk
about hydration during summer time
some people feel so hot and sweaty they
don't want to use moisturizers although
you need to use moisturizer morning and
night just choose lighter moisturizer
okay or
choose liquid hydration such as
hydrating toners okay and you can spritz
your skin
throughout your whole day by opening
your makeup
oh my god the smells in here i'm just
okay i can't i cannot wait to try this
because i know that smells so good so
let's talk about um you know protection
and moisturizer for your skin you have
the mermaid facial the hydrafacial and
the pearls glow facials so let's start
with the mermaid because this is brand
new right yeah brand new we just
launched it it's the whole head to toe
facial
and it is designed to introduce skin to
vitamins nutrients and trace elements
from the sea
fetamere has been around for 40 years
and they use a lot of seaweed in the
product
to infuse the skin with vitamins
nutrients trace elements okay well kathy
i can't take it anymore i need to know
what i'm smelling what it did
so the mermaid facial starts with marine
sponge which is a plant and it starts
with gentle exfoliation of the skin so
it increases blood circulation okay um
as well as provides gentle exfoliation
and you do that head to toe head to toe
we start with the body then we apply
especially bubbly
a special bubbly seaweed mud
that feels very warm on the skin and
bubbly so it provides detoxification
contours we need to get ready for some
summer with contouring
improve cellulite
appearance hydrates the skin and it
feels very relaxing because the bubbles
massage
you gently while you wrap them special
foil it's like heating blanket yeah i'm
just i'm imagining this all over and
that's amazing yeah and you have special
membership programs for this facial the
hydrafacial and
all the services right tell us about
that yes we just launched new website
all of the information is there for sure
guys to find but when you sign up for
membership is six months you get special
pricing you get twenty percent off on
retail and additional twenty percent on
all of the additional treatments that
you decide to get throughout the six
months that is incredible thank you and
where are you guys located because
you're pretty new to town uh no we've
been open for seven years now oh yes
we are off saharan fort apache
right next to the library okay good to
know thank you so much katya and i'm
just going to sniff this while i smell
yes i'm just going to smell this while i
read the stuff you don't mind
thank you to pearlskin studios for
sponsoring this segment all you got to
do is call 702-525-5504
and don't forget about their special
offers you purchase a six-month
hydrafacial or pearls glow facial
membership in july and receive six
months of facial treatments and 20 off
all retail products that is amazing yes
yes this is incredible
i'll send it to you
well welcome to town pearl skin studio